The field has changed as different perspectives
have come in and certainly
a female perspective is very very useful.
I actually don't think,
people have made the argument that
maybe it's because the field is sexist.
but I don't think that it's that.
I think that it is truly truly an example of
your personal biases.
I am personally biased in how I ask my questions
but if I'm in this field and then
and there are men who are asking
their personally  biased questions of the field,
then together we will come up
with something that's going to give
us a more complete answer.
Same thing as you know, I'm also latina.
And so as a minority I also have a different way
of looking at things
that you know other people may not have.
For example, the fact that I am
really outgoing and I'm not shy
talking about sex and copulation and things like that.
Somebody who comes from a different culture
may find that a lot more difficult to do
and so I can come in and I can filll that gap.
And that's the beauty of having
diverse perspectives in science.
It's that everybody comes, we all have them,
our personal biases, but if we give room
to enough people with those different ideas
and those different backgrounds
then overall science is going to be better.
And so that's really the cool part of the story I think.